[Musik]
mysteriöse Laserstrahlen am Himmel über
Hawaii
nur eine gute Sekunde dauert das
Phänomen am Nachthimmel und sorgt
weltweit für große Aufregung es scheint
als werde hier die Erde gescannt aus dem
All nur wer oder was steckt dahinter
sind Außerirdische am Werk oder
spionieren hier wieder die Chinesen die
USA aus
eingefangen hat die unheimliche
lichtschauende Januar ein japanisches
forschungsteleskop auf Hawaii von bloßem
Auge sind die Strahlen kaum zu erkennen
mit fotofiltern machen sie die
Wissenschaftler gut sichtbar wie in
einem Science-Fiction-Film pushen ganz
schnell mehrere grüne Laserstrahlen um 2
Uhr nachts durch den dunklen Himmel dann
sind sie verschwunden
Tage davor fällt dasselbe japanische
Teleskop ein anderes bizarres
Himmelsschauspiel dieses Mal gleitet
eine blaue Spirale über den Himmel
hier gibt es schnell eine Erklärung von
Experten Grund für das himmelsmysterium
sei der Staat einer space extra Rakete
und die abgesprengten Raketenstufen die
zur Erde trudeln
bei mysteriösen grünen strahlenteppich
steckt aber keine Rakete dahinter auch
keine Außerirdischen es ist ein Satellit
der die Erde vermisst nur woher stammt
er die NASA sagt sie haben nichts damit
zu tun westliche Wissenschaftler sind
sich einig es handelt sich um einen
chinesischen Flugkörper der Satellit sei
vor knapp einem Jahr gestartet und solle
die atmosphärische Verschmutzung Messen
an dieser Erklärung bleiben zumindest
Zweifel nach den mysteriösen
spionageballons jetzt also der nächste
Aufreger zwischen China und den USA
durch den grünen Laser aus dem All
[Musik]